[Musik]
mädels ist reicht es aus wenn wir nur
alle zwei wochen des bad krozinger
vergiss es wir müssen öfter putzen visa
ich gratuliere dir du hast noch einen
job du kannst täglich das bad putzen
witzig hat auf ich weiß gerade ich das
ja alles schaffen soll was denn die
sprachkurse die ehrenamtlichen sachen
ich will mich weiter engagieren die
arbeit gefällt mir aber durch den job
habe ich einfach keine zeit mehr
ja kein problem haben sie sowieso nichts
zu sagen
[Applaus]
der plan sieht vor aus sie ist die seite
können wir dir helfen
ich weiß nicht vielleicht können wir
erst mal eine aufgabe einer wg bei dem
für die ersten wochen
sebastian kann für dich das bad putzen
erfasst ach das wird den ich schade nur
mit mehr übung trotzdem auch schneller
sehr witzig nico was sagst du dazu
ja warum danke leute das ist nur für ein
paar wochen ich mach das wieder gut
[Musik]